hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 71
Seneca tells his correspondent and by
extension those of us who are reading
him that one of the key things we we
need to do is to focus upon what the
supreme or highest good the supremum
bonum is for us human beings and it's
going to be the same for all of us
although we don't all necessarily
realize that as a matter of fact most of
us don't have a clear sight according to
Seneca of what the supreme good is and
that's a real problem and he tells us
why if we don't understand what the
supreme good is then we're gonna have
some problems he says how is advice to
be found advice about specific things
let me explain each time you want to
know what to pursue or what to avoid so
that's a fundamental set of concerns for
ethics right look to your highest good
the aim of your life as a whole
everything we do ought to be in
accordance with that aim and you might
say oh that's perfect I'm doing Values
Clarification here I want to make a ton
of money and be able to retire by 35 or
I want to pursue as many pleasures as
possible or I want to rack up all of
these successes that will make me feel
like the the big person that I didn't
get from my teachers or parents that
validation and some who say well no no
those are not the supreme good you're
actually off target there and target is
a good metaphor you know if we if we are
aiming at the wrong thing we're gonna be
making the wrong decision so he says
only a person who has the entirety of
their life and view is in a position to
arrange life's particulars even with
paints all at the ready no one can
render a likeness until he's decided
what he wants to paint you need to have
some sort of plan so he says everyone
deliberates over parts of life no one
over life as a whole and this is another
one where we could think of lots of
examples somebody who thinks it's really
all about making a ton of money they
focus totally on that and then their
relationships go to crap or for their
character or their health or all sorts
of other things and some people are
obsessed with about health and their
relationships go to crap because of it
or other people focus totally on their
career and then they don't focus on
these other things so Seneca says if you
want to shoot an arrow you must know
what you are trying to hit only then can
you direct the point and study the shaft
our councils are all astray in that they
have no mark to aim at so what should we
emit well what the supreme good is and
he he tells us if we want to understand
it at least this is what the Stoics
teach we have to grasp that the highest
good is as he says what is honorable the
highest good simply is what is honorable
quote hone s them asked and hone s them
is a latin phrase that is a bit
difficult to translate we actually get
the word honesty from it but in the
sense of integrity right that which has
intrinsic value that which good people
recognize as good and it translates the
Greek Agathon and also the Greek Kallang
which are also difficult I mean Agathon
is easy
good but good in what sense cologne is a
bit more difficult to translate
honourable is is a way of describing it
honourable it doesn't have the gripping
power that it has that it had in the
past for us present people that which is
intrinsically worthwhile that which is
intrinsically valuable you can even be
translated as the beautiful or the fine
so that is what the highest good is and
what we ought to be orienting our life
around and what does that mean for the
Stoics what is honorable virtue virtue
and the virtues remember the Stoics
acknowledge four cardinal virtues same
that that plato by the way acknowledged
and show up in other virtue ethics that
a wisdom justice temperance and courage
with all of the other virtues that fall
under these that is what the highest
good is and when Seneca decides to try
to define the virtue which is a
difficult thing to do in any really
helpful way he does so a little bit
later on he says what is this virtue
true and unshakable judgment now that
doesn't sound like what other virtue
ethicists will say you know Aristotle
would say well that's a habit and it's
choice worthy and you know it's going to
bear on actions and passions and certain
kinds of goods and all that why is
Seneca talking about judgment here well
because for the Stoics the virtues are
not just in terms of our actions and not
just habits they are cognitive they have
to do with viewpoints on what is good
and what is bad and how we ought to
behave and how we ought to prioritize so
each of those virtues wisdom justice
temperance courage involves a true and
unshakable judgment and he says from
this come the impulses of the mind by
this every impression that stimulates
impulses rendered perfectly clear so
he's telling us how the virtues actually
function and this is worth pausing on
for just a
from this come the impulses of the mind
if so impulses is translating the Latin
in petram Greek or may it can also be
translated as not just impulse but
choices is is a word that that's used
for in the Greek for form a in the stoic
texts and because we have these correct
judgments we are naturally led to desire
the right things be averse to the right
things have the right emotional
reactions or lack of reactions engage in
the right actions and then he also adds
every impression that stimulates impulse
is rendered perfectly clear we're
constantly flooded both from the outside
and from our own screwed-up insides with
all sorts of things that the Stoics call
impressions or appearances in Greek
fantasy I write and these impressions
are taken in by us and then if we want
to exercise the opportunity to you know
judge them we do otherwise we sort of
automatically respond to them and then
impulse arises from that and then that
leads to our actions and choices right
our decisions our commitments for better
for worse so virtue helps us to manage
all of these things properly he also
tells us and this is just a little bit
later it will be consonant with this
judgment to regard all things that are
associated with virtue as goods and is
equal to each other so there's two
different points there there they're all
goods so you know a relationship in
which we confirm each other in virtue
right a friendship of that sort would be
a good buy you know contrast a
relationship in which we are making each
other worse or impeding each other in
virtue that would be bad morally bad it
would be bad because it derives from the
virtue that's ultimately the source of
good or bad these supreme good right in
this case supreme bad of course would be
vice we can also judge people as the
ones that have virtues as good we can
judge
actions as good so virtue is what makes
things in general good and then there's
this this you know assertion that all
things associated with virtue are goods
and equal to each other so this leads us
into what the Stoics acknowledged as a
paradox that is something that's a
little bit hard to swallow it's
counterintuitive it makes you say wait a
second I'm not sure about that
and the Stoics did in fact assert what
we call the Equality of goods if we want
to use Cicero's formulation and the
stoic paradoxes what this means is that
they said virtues insofar as they
actually are virtues are equal to each
other doesn't matter what they're being
exercised in what circumstances what
matter to use the term that Seneca is
employing here they're all the same
on a moral level they're all up here at
the highest level and everything else is
down here except for Vice which is way
way down at the bottom is something bad
so he gives you a lot of examples
historical examples of people who are
virtuous and vicious and we're not going
to go through all of these but let's
look at a few so this is something that
he realizes is counterintuitive
he says what do you mean does it not
matter whether Cato one of the great
stoic philosophers and statesmen is
elected prate or or rejected does it
make no difference at all whether he's
defeated at Pharsalus or defeats his
enemy is this good that he has in
remaining and conquerable when his side
is defeated really equal to the good he
would have had if he'd won that battle
return to his homeland and established
peace so these are some good questions
right if you know anything about the
history of Cato if you don't you
probably want to check him out Seneca
says yeah why not virtue while defeating
adversity is just the same as it is
while holding the line in the midst of
prosperity virtue cannot be made larger
or smaller it has but the one
sighs which is just enough the right
size for it and he goes on and gives
example after example but you know you
can see what what the point of all of
this is he goes on and says Cato's
honorable life is not a greater good
than his honorable death virtue does not
admit of augmentation or growth and this
is you know a very important idea so
it's not as he says the material itself
but virtue itself that makes things good
or bad and he actually uses the word for
making there and thicket right it's what
makes the things good things or makes
the things bad things so virtue is going
to be the source of goodness and
likewise you can say well how would
virtue make something bad that's a
little bit of a puzzler well I would
tell you don't do that thing over there
we can think about how does courage or
you know any of the parts of courage
like endurance high mindedness that you
see him talking about in here actual
like facing fear or courage how do these
things make anything else bad because
they provide you with a sort of light or
lens by which you can look at abandoning
your your commitments and say oh yeah
that that in fact would be vicious that
would be bad there would be the opposite
of what I ought to do in this
circumstance what the judgment is
telling me to do so there's the answer
to that there's a lot of particularly in
in this translation a lot of discussion
that has to do with the word measure and
this is a little bit of a you know
optical illusion perhaps created by the
translations but I want to talk about
some of these phrases so he tells us
that virtue takes the measure of all
things and nothing measures virtue
now the latin term there is
utakata coming utakata right judges is
another way of thinking about it but
what happens when you're judging you're
actually in some respect imposing a kind
of proportion or measure on things so
virtue tells us how we ought to take
things how we ought to use things how we
ought to deal with things how we ought
to place them in proportion to other
things and nothing else does this with
virtue now why does he say that well
because there's plenty of other people
and plenty of other moral theories that
would say that something else measures
virtue think for example of people who
say things like you know when you're
doing business with people you should be
honest because that's going to improve
your bottom line okay so if honesty is a
virtue
which would fall under justice right
fair dealings with people and we could
we could say you should be just in your
business dealings because that leads to
a good bottom line the good bottom line
is the point there and if you could have
the good bottom line without being just
screw being just get rid of it right in
that case the good bottom line which is
probably a measure a number right is
measuring the importance the quality the
commitment to virtue and that's getting
things completely mixed up virtue could
tell you that's getting things mixed up
you don't actually listen to virtue as a
matter of fact you'd probably have to as
he says a little bit earlier in here not
just love virtue but have a burning
desire for a virtue right he also tells
us that virtue does not increase why
because it has its measure and if he
actually also says it's this measure is
full so he what is the measure here
números zuo's interestingly here's
here's using the word number virtues got
its number we might say in the you know
phrase or I say I've got your number
buddy
well virtue it has its own measure
within itself and then he also talks
about a little bit later in in this
action he says coming back to the
question of the the Equality of things
what's this reclining at dinner is equal
to being tortured and says does this
surprise you here's something that will
amaze you even more reclining at dinner
is bad and lying on the rack is good if
the one is done in a disgraceful or
vicious manner and the other honorably
or virtuous it is not the material as we
said that makes them good or bad but
virtue
wherever virtue appears everything is as
he says of the same measure and the same
value and here he is actually using the
word that we it's you know cognate for
measure I used to them the same men
sooner I at plenty of the same measure
the same proportionality and value the
same award is another way of thinking
about it
the last thing that we have to talk
about that's quite important in this
particular letter where he's telling us
about the supreme good but also telling
us an awful lot of useful stuff about
how the Stoics understood virtue is that
we we need to understand that we are not
the exemplar the sage and treat
ourselves accordingly so he says that
the wise person vanquishes misfortune
through courage many who profess wisdom
but don't actually have wisdom are
terrified by the most trivial of threats
at this point the fault is ours
why demanding the same from one who is
making progress as from the sage now the
one who's making progress in greek the
Stoics called that person a pro cult on
and that is translated in latin by a
proficient ace right is the plural of
that so those who are making progress
who are not yet entirely virtuous but
but are on the way to it they don't have
the same capacities as the sage and
seneca tells you about his own case I am
still persuading myself of the
principles I extol I am NOT
that fully convinced and even if I were
I would not have the lessons so well
prepared so well practices they have
them to spring to my defense in every
tribulation and here he uses a metaphor
that he employs in many other places
just as some dyes are readily absorbed
by the wool or others only have to
repeat its soaking and simmering so
there are studies that show up well in
our minds as soon as we've learned them
this one though must permeate us
thoroughly it must soak in giving not
just a tinge of color but a real deep
dye or it cannot deliver on any of its
promises and a little bit earlier he
talks about you know the sage as also
being human here we go he says I do not
put the sage in a separate class from
the rest of humankind
neither do I eliminate pain and grief
from him as if he were some sort of rock
not susceptible to any feeling I keep in
mind that he's made of two parts one is
non rational that's what experiences the
biting the burning the pain the other
part is rational it is this that holds
unshakable opinions and that is fearless
an unconquered ball in this latter
resides the highest good of humankind
before that good is filled out the mind
is uncertain and in turmoil but when it
has been perfected the mind is stable
and unmoved and so he talks about the
person who's made a start the one who's
committed to virtue but still ascending
will sometimes slack off and allow their
concentration to falter so we've got the
sage on the one hand who's still human
but has managed to you know become
virtuous in a full sense and then we
have the person who recognizes that
virtue is the high is good and they're
they're working at it they're working at
it now a good question is is virtue
increasing in them and and Seneca would
say virtue is not increasing that
person's capacity to grasp to understand
to make use of virtue
that's what's increasing so the virtue
itself remains the same the virtue is
the highest good that that person in
some sense is drawing upon so this is a
this is a very important letter because
it tells us an awful lot about how
Seneca and his stoic school understand
virtue not just as the highest good but
as
which makes other things good or by
extension
an opposition bad
you